it's always better to travel abroad with
a friend and I brought a great one one
of the stars of HBO's veep and a man
with Ghanaian roots Sam Richardson tell
me what do you know about Ghana your
your mom's from Ghana my mom's from guy
I live here back and forth between here
in Detroit right did you say that you
know Detroit better or Ghana better but
I'd probably be more of an expert on
Detroit yeah okay well nice to tell us
now yeah we're here you have family here
I do my mom's here and my cousins yeah
if they watch the veep all they did
that's a filthy show even someone oh you
know who I am
I don't know baby's kind of Who I am how
are you I'm good
what is your name my name is Musa Musa I
come from Chicago
[Laughter]
[Music]
how's the United States it's a [ __ ] show
right now yeah yeah it's a bit of pure
mess yes you can go there but not right
now yeah give it like two years why
maybe two things now you don't want this
hair you can wear my hair do you want to
wear that the guy in the shirt is like
please please take that off please
we're here at the McCallum market that's
the big like shopping square market yeah
in here in Accra and as you can it's
really chaotic in there and we were told
you really need a guide you are going to
translate for us in the market yes
do you speak English you don't speak
English I speak cheap and you speak
let's be barely to tweet very little
between a good English right this is a
mess what can't wait she stops traffic
herself
she is so hard to keep up with it's like
eleven it's the same it's the same yeah
this my kids anytime is a problem in the
market at all they come to you yes and
then you take care you know what if two
people are fighting what if one person
saying I want to sell the coconuts here
and the other person saying no I want to
sell the fruit here and they're fighting
what do you do we don't do that yet I
can I can fight fight someone no you we
don't do that no you don't fight in that
market but I like to fight in - if you
fight in the markets you Vavoom
what I will get these items yes but you
go back to the market because this one
got you one piece I'm a good fighter no
no no we don't fight here we are all one
people
I'll stop bringing up fighting no no you
don't fight soon good we don't fight but
yeah okay we don't fight in this match
okay yes that's my established we've
established that there's no fighting
here okay now say someone were to
pugilism in ancient we don't do that no
no we are law-abiding citizens and for
that matter we respect every rule and
regulations in this market there's
really no fights no fighting no no no I
don't know who started that
this is a good color for me yes you can
pay for your life away from my sister
yes what about my girlfriend no no no no
but my wife likes my girlfriend no I
know in this not that you don't do
boyfriend-girlfriend yo we are half
husband and wife
so we don't deal in boyfriend/girlfriend
so if you come from your country you're
going to do pretty much everything you
could imagine
in this market and everybody's balancing
things on their head like effortless
balance Italy I don't know why we
haven't learned that you know I am these
international spoke sweetheart Kirk
choco milk
[Applause]
and we agree on most everything except
when it comes to perf
I like perk milk and I like perfect shot
go I say no
choco
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]